très vite tu décides de te spécialiser
dans un type de danse la danse en talon
comment tu as eu l'idée en fait
je pense que tout est parti de ma mère
merde mais ma mère avait déjà plus de
300 paires de talons quand j'ai grandi
enfin j'ai grandi vraiment autour de la
pompe elle est travaillée
[Rires]
donc j'ai grandi dans la danse et elle a
toujours aimé la mode etc et tout
bêtement après
c'est venu comme ça j'ai donné trois
jours
c'est Mehdi Arnaud mes acolytes oui tout
bêtement un jour en cours de danse j'ai
voulu faire une choré sexy j'ai dit au
fil de les ramener et je crois qu'il y
avait une petite meuf qui m'a dit mais
j'arrive pas tu vas voir c'est trop dur
elle avait ma taille que je faisais des
petits pièges je suis 41 je lui dis bah
vas-y donne fais voir et puis j'y suis
arrivé très très bien et après j'ai
compris qu'il y avait un truc à faire il
y a un délire à faire c'est ça t'exposes
sur les réseaux tes vidéos YouTube font
des millions de vues regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maintenant c'est pas possible alors tu
participes à des concours de danse à la
télé très vite tu as participé en
premier à l'émission La Meilleure danse
en 2012 sur le titre ils sont pas non
fous les de ouf mais regardez ça donnait
ça
[Musique]
je n'ai pas revu je n'ai pas revu ces
images depuis final
on est allé en finale impossible
et 2 ans après on se retrouve en finale
de l'émission Got Talent
[Rires]
pas répéter le titre 2014
mais la version
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
regardez finaliste ah ouais j'adore
c'est incroyable
en ce moment non tu fais tout le temps
dès que tu vois quelque chose il y a une
danse qui devient oui je suis très
facilement inspiré je suis comme toi moi
un truc un petit truc c'est moi je suis
un chien exactement
[Rires]
dans un clip de Céline Dion oui ah ouais
tu étais dans le costume de Deadpool
regarder
les secrets
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la chanson dans l'oreille toute la
journée un jour c'est vrai et ouais m'a
chanté un petit bout de pour que tu
m'aimes encore
[Rires]
j'ai compris tous les mots
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes restés en contact ou pas avec
Céline non mais bon elle est géniale
j'adore moi je suis fou de Céline Dion
alors on t'a vu aussi qui en a eu
t'étais ami avec Hélène Pompeo Meredith
Grey Grey's
en commun à New York après un cours
était également pote alors voilà avec
qui attends parce que je sais plus
[Musique]
j'ai vraiment ouais je suis fan depuis
toujours donc ça c'est un des jobs quand
on m'a annoncé ça qu'elle était
intéressé pour que la cote j'y croyais
pas du tout ça commence à arriver Mariah
Carey veut que tu la côte c'était pas de
la danse c'était vraiment du coaching
justement apprendre à marcher à prendre
la positionner en talon elle va elle
redémarrer une tournée donc je l'ai un
petit peu coaché sur des positions de
corps on appelle ça movement coach vous
pourriez coacher Siri par exemple sur
des mouvements
[Musique]
et Mariah Carey Mariah Carey elle t'a
appelé c'est quelqu'un qui t'a appelé à
un moment quand tu la rencontre
elle m'a appelé Younes pendant deux
semaines c'est pas grave ça ça peut
m'appeler comme tu veux bien sûr
elle était super elle est géniale et
voilà pour le coup c'est très bien
entendu et c'est vraiment pareil à notre
souvenir mais plus que je retiens encore
plus parce que je suis fan depuis petit
de mariage donc pour moi c'était
vraiment surréal d'être deux semaines
avec nous on a Maria tarif
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
S
et tu es en contact avec elle ou pas
encore non plus avec rien non plus je
sais qu'elle voit
si on n'a jamais d'y arriver d'envoyer
deux trois messages je sais qu'elle est
libre mais elle moi aussi
elle m'envoie deux trois messages je
l'ai dit
non mais c'est vrai moi aussi elle
arrête pas de m'écrire et j'ai dit Maria
lève le pied ma chérie qui a des galets
incroyable
alors après tu es devenu le nouveau
professeur de danse de la Star Ac tu
connaissais la star acade ou pas du tout
ouais je connaissais très bien c'est ma
génération donc j'ai grandi devant alors
tu as commencé tu as fait une entrée
remarquable franchement et ton régalé
ils m'ont sorti
parce que j'ai vu l'oseille sur ta
rencontre j'étais un peu en Shrek
[Musique]
qui est avec nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
danser ou pas non pas du tout je
l'aurais pas fait c'était juste ouais
parce que ils ont qu'à regarder tu vois
ils m'ont contacté donc
pas m'apprendre à faire mon métier moi
aussi s'ils veulent de moi j'ai pas
besoin qu'il voit danser ils connaissent
mes capacités
un personnage exceptionnel comme ça pour
voir comment vous étiez devant la caméra
tout ça ouais je pense c'était plus le
côté télé est-ce que je suis capable de
donner des cours
en carrière derrière moi et pas que tu
es fan de Madonna aussi je suis le plus
grand fan
j'ai vu quasiment tous les derniers
concerts de la Madone mais je l'ai pas
rencontré personnellement j'ai eu
l'occasion et j'ai refusé parce que
justement j'ai peur on m'a toujours dit
de pas rencontrer des sucres
[Rires]
je voyais des chiens qui pétaient des
chiens qui tombaient
jamais jamais jamais alors au-delà
d'être un monstre de la danse c'est
aussi très très darka regardez on a fait
une petite compil là c'est quand même
[Musique]
tu vois comment tu fais l'oiseau
au bord de la route
[Applaudissements]
vous avez été exceptionnel dans la Star
Ac mais vous avez quand même largement
dominé les autres coachs etc est-ce que
vous avez parfois senti des petites
jalousies de vos collègues
non non mais on est jalousie je pense
que en fait c'est oui non non le mot non
jalousie non parce que déjà on est tous
très différents pour être très honnête
et je vais être vraiment honnête je
pense qu'il y avait même pas essayer de
faire une petite compétition avec moi
j'étais déjà trop loin dès le départ et
trop sûr de moi donc je pense qu'ils
sont calmés dès le départ
parce que dès le départ si tu veux j'ai
ouvert avec un show alors que les autres
on m'a présenté avec déjà un petit peu
plus
donc il y a pas eu de compétition enfin
c'était un peu perdu d'entrée tu as
raison ouais bah oui bah oui bah oui
technique au niveau des des chevilles
parce que quand on a des talons très
très haut on risque de se fouler très
rapidement enfin les chevilles est-ce
qu'il y a des entraînements spéciaux
enfin des des la musculation au niveau
des chevilles pour pouvoir
entraînement spécifique pour porter des
talons après on va pour danser comme ça
oui après moi je donne des cours de
danse en talon où j'ai une technique
c'est quoi la technique en fait il faut
faute déjà moi je dansais je faisais de
la danse classique très jeune donc après
c'est la posture je faisais des pointes
déjà là c'est que pour les filles donc
tu as toute une une danse
je faisais des pointes à 10 ans je crois
11 ans
classique après tu as fait quoi danse
classique jazz contemporain jazz moderne
jazz
c'est la base
c'est la base mon ancien
actuellement tu vois actuellement
[Musique]
mais j'ai l'impression que vous brûlez
d'envie de faire un petit peu
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous dire
la vérité franchement
c'est comme je vous dire j'ai fait des
arts martiaux j'ai pas le droit de me
battre en dehors du tatami
de danser voilà face à un collègue voilà
quand on est du même niveau on n'a pas
envie toi
non plus ça va vous sinon vous voulez
[Rires]
combien de temps il vous faut pour lui
mettre des talons et qui dansent comme
vous comme la chorégraphie
trois mois non 3 mois
et vous avez déjà vu danser c'est pour
ça que j'ai 3 mois
je prends très mal
mais danser dans son salon c'est
différent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai vu un petit truc ouais
c'est beau
sensualité contre
toi
c'est incroyable si vous avez des
questions je suis en train de refaire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas mal fait très bien Yanis mars
j'ai pas été pris deux fois en ce
moment-là
je sais pas toi c'était toi mais je suis
bien je suis bien content au final les
choses se font bien parce que je
quand on m'a proposé dams la première
année on parlait pas du retour de la
Star Ac d'accord donc j'étais intéressé
ceci dit quand j'ai fait les screen test
j'avais fait les deux en même temps
Sarah et dals et je voulais vraiment
faire comme le mec qui rit il a fait
Daniel et Delphine
comme quoi les choses sont bien faites
aussi en amour non mais c'est ça
c'est fou ça tu vois comme un doute